what is your dating range lately 31 to
coffin
[Music]
selena gomez is back at it on tick tock
poking fun at her love life oh my
goodness yeah the 29 year old triple
threat shared this clip on tick tock
what is your dating range lately 31 to
coffin
[Music]
that's the former child star lip dubbing
anisha on bravo's family karma what is
your dating range lately 31 to coffin
and by now come on guys we know selena
slays a tick tock lip sync moment
what is your dating range lately 31 to
coffin
[Music]
cell has since deleted that clip from
her account but not before anisha shared
her reaction
what is your dating range lately
the reality star captioned the clip
quote selena gomez i love you thank you
and she doubled down on all that over on
instagram writing selena i'm shook i
love you i hope everybody enjoys it of
course this is hardly the first time the
only murders in the building star has
mocked her dating life on tic toc
no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single it's a
real thing it's fine
[Music]
the texas native recently insisted she's
totally cool with her single status and
back in march selena who previously
dated justin bieber and the weeknd
shared this clip i mean i'm just really
trying to highlight you forever how
about me for what
you said holler at me for what
the caption maybe this is why i'm single
don't believe a damn word
i mean you're pretty
and last month she brought the lols with
this moment last time i was single i was
24 and the dating pool was everyone and
now it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that that's
selena lip-syncing to this scene of
leslie mann's character in the other
woman last time i was single i was 24
and the dating pool was everyone and now
it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that the
actress who turns 30 in july captioned
the hilarious clip quote me walking into
my 30s i'm okay with it though i'm just
so confident and while selena has been
trolling her own dating life on the app
as she approaches her 30th birthday in
july
hopefully anisha can provide some
comfort because the 36 year old just got
engaged and shared the happy news on her
podcast
cheers to you and cheers to me
i'm engaged
i am one of the luckiest girls in the
world i am so happy
i am over the moon
[Music]
you